let's talk about that explosion
it was late afternoon in beirut people
were watching a huge fire take hold in
the port
but no one expected this
one
two days after the disaster more than
135 people have died
we may never know the real number
ambulances continue to arrive at the
scene of the
explosion thousands were injured
[Music]
beirut's governor says more than 300 000
people are now homeless
so what do we know about why this
happened what is it about lebanon that
makes this so much
worse and how will a country that's
almost bankrupt
rebuild again
[Music]
lebanon was already on its knees debt
poverty
conflict a paralyzed government
corruption money that's almost
worthless and then this
[Music]
everyone has a story of survival or
tragedy
[Music]
it's hard to make sense of the
devastation but this is what the port
area used to look like
it's surrounded by people's homes and
that's the warehouse by the water where
nearly 3 000 tons of ammonium nitrate
were being stored
the chemical is a common fertilizer but
you can use it to make explosives
that's what a bomber did in oklahoma
city in 1995.
the fertilizer arrived at the port on a
vessel that was having technical
problems
it was then reportedly impounded over
the years requests to do something about
it either by selling it locally or
exporting it
were apparently sent to the courts but
nothing happened
and now they're trying to figure out
who's responsible for the explosion
the president of lebanon says an
investigation into the beirut port
explosion will look at whether it was
caused by negligence
an accident or possible external
interference
people in lebanon also want answers and
will anger
only stop and we can only look back
again normally if we see those bastards
in prison may they all rot in heaven
people are in shock but anger is also
growing at a political class many blame
for mismanagement
and being responsible for running the
economy into the ground
it's an economic crisis made much worse
by a pandemic
and lockdowns but they were protesting
long before coven 19.
to understand what's behind lebanon's
economic and political crisis
here's part of our explainer from back
in february
[Music]
protesters say they're fed up with a lot
of things
the economy high taxes lack of jobs
crumbling infrastructure
and they say the biggest problem is
rampant corruption
which has thrived under lebanon's
sectarian political system
we're going to explain that system in a
second but let's get a sense of just
how tough everyday life is for most
lebanese people
we don't really have access to proper
public services like there's no 24 7
electricity
there's no clean accessible drinking
water we have piles of garbage all over
the country
sewage is not treated it goes straight
out to the
the ocean uh so it feels like the state
is absent
from daily life uh in lebanon most
people agree that mess is caused by
serious mismanagement some say it's
because of corruption
but you'll also hear analysts say that
lebanon never really recovered from a
long
and devastating war
[Music]
we're talking about lebanon's civil war
which started in 1975 and went on for 15
years
militias from different sects and
political groups fought each other for
dominance
and also fought among themselves then
syria and israel got involved
and the battles became even more
destructive
at the end of the war lebanon's main
political groups signed the taif
agreement to make sure they all got a
slice of political power
and that's really the basis for
lebanon's political system
today a maronite christian gets the
presidency the prime minister has to be
a sunni muslim
and the speaker of parliament is always
a shia muslim
in parliament seats are shared 50 50
between muslims and christians
but in reality there are two big
political alliances which include
parties from different sects
and they each have rival foreign powers
backing them
march 14 was former prime minister saad
hariri's bloc
which has the support of saudi arabia
and the u.s
march 8 is the block that includes the
maronite christian president
michelle owns party and hezbollah it has
syria and iran support
so because of all of those overlapping
and competing interests
many people will tell you that lebanon's
sectarian political system
isn't really sectarian what's really
happening in lebanon is that
there are political parties that used to
be militias
sex are not fighting in lebanon it's
really
opposing warlords backed by opposing
foreign powers and this is how many say
corruption has gotten so out of hand
many of those powerful
political leaders or the zwama as
they're called in lebanon
are said to have focused on their own
political and financial gains
and made themselves very rich
lebanon has 220 kilometers of coast 180
kilometers of the coast has been
privatized
it's now under the control of either
former officials
and people who are close to them i'll
just give you one example
apart meters in beirut the revenues were
not going to the state
they were going to a private company
controlled owned by people who are close
to politicians
there's been no real signs of change
since then and how the port is allowed
to run is seen as a big
part of the problem in his coverage of
the explosion
our beirut correspondent put it this way
it's not lost on beirut's residence that
this tragedy emanated from the city's
port
a public utility known locally as the
cave of alibaba and the 40 thieves
he talks about allegations of bribes
billions of dollars in tax revenue from
the port disappearing
and since the pandemic things have gone
from bad
to worse the government is nearly
bankrupt
lebanon already had the world's third
highest level of debt relative to its
gdp
its currency the lira has lost 85
percent of its value against the dollar
and inflation is rising by more than 50
percent a month
food has become unaffordable for so many
people
back in january people had hoped a new
government would improve things
their main goal this year was to push
through reforms to qualify for
international aid
but the politicians haven't been able to
agree and talks with the international
monetary fund
are on hold it's not anger for the sake
of anger
it's not it's not a an impossibility to
have in lebanon
competent people to to to to govern and
to serve their people
let there be accountability let's have a
transparent investigation
right now people in lebanon are asking
themselves how in the world the country
is ever going to recover
who's going to rebuild beirut and
where's the money going to come from to
pay for an
estimated 15 billion dollars worth of
damage
how is its health system going to treat
thousands of injured people and those
sick with covid19
after at least three hospitals have been
destroyed
and where is a country that's almost
entirely reliant on imports from the sea
going to get food from when it's port is
a crater
even before the explosion politicians in
lebanon
couldn't find common ground so now
something and someone's got to give
to stand any chance of sorting out this
mess
because you can only push people so far
lots of details are still emerging about
what happened in beirut
so to get the latest make sure to visit
aljazeera.com where our reporters on the
ground
are following all the latest
developments i'll see you next week